there comes on tough shot left hand
Simmons up high rebounds and threads it
down the paint for two showing you to
make 3-point shots a doe run by Boston
thanks to the three-point ball by will
here
[Applause]
he reaches up to the rebound paces up
fancy pass and it's down
how about again Ben Simmons showing it
behind the back you're just born with it
it's the sixth sense huh
great motion and the bucket falls he
looks like he's got a hand off there and
then he catches Allen in the forty seven
seven school great feed then Simmons
with the diamond waits for it
flip bowling past traffic you know how
he got it up to him Simmons
[Applause]
assist control five-on-five images
alright the Commissioner will be
speaking when that happens we will take
you to it on NBA TV he never looks at
him and that's what makes that play
works a lot of times in the defender
you're looking at the eyes of the
offensive player and just think of the
Warriors English got stuck in the air
and the water right the passing ability
on display for homes and the finish out
of transition watch well this has been
an interesting game him came wet came
over late in the season was really good
for you so that's a lot of veteran
Phillip I know that's what then fitments
could do I mean he can make plays that
other guys can't even see but look at
this pass here just right as Drive
that's when you can make those kinds of
pass and that is capela out dueling and
beat Clint capela 11th in the NBA and
rebounds per game he runs the floor
great recognition by Robert Covington
and there is an bead leaking and evil
solo see Robert did meet like that
you'll often
good rule Amir Johnson
goodbye indeed the last time they were
in the plows was 2012 got to the second
round that year and her some of the
basket Simmons with the dish
and a three-point opportunity jumping
much more including James one of our NBA
Wednesday doubleheader between Cleveland
Charlotte and feed from Simmons and MP
now with 15 points
Simmons bodies up on Iguodala one more
for home
[Applause]
the creator you can see the spin move on
egg with Allen everyone moves when Ben
has the ball there is Michonne making
himself available Vicki with the late
pal about the bench in Giotto without
there with Robert Covington JJ reddick
this guy Dario sharukh goes backdoor to
Simmons one more oh and feed that my
friends is basketball here's the ball
move into nice little behind of that
pass to play 151 or not goes inside and
beat with the block he's one of the top
shot blockers in the game Simmons the
other way
[Applause]
and the brain but what though to have
your cinnamon the six is aggressive
defensively and quite frankly Cavaliers
out of sync
Simmons ice lead on for Covington it'll
be a timeout Tehran Lou here's Ben
Simmons and incredibly impressive start
to his rookie year and he gets an assist
they're finding homes all along in the
game the other night against Indiana and
Paul George's return to Indianapolis is
Andy gets it down and finishes on a nice
pass from Ben Simmons start he wall Joe
alibied six early points for the Sixers
yep fine be that time victimizing Murray
Simmons has company it is Charlotte who
delivers to defensively against ultra
book that's not his game you little dad
nice bug yeah the great spot by Simmons
hitting charge and stride the vision the
willingness to pass the nice catch it
finished seasons his second go-round
with the Pacers fourth on the team in
scoring averaging just under 13 Ben
Simmons dropping a dime on Amir Johnson
for his second assist you love playing
with guys like that
because those are the guys that keep you
out on the floor of the place picked up
gorgeous look by Bensimon hard to sell a
house quickly has begun that long
Gabrielle said yeah you're keeping the
house beautifully done by sense I mean
[Applause]
[Music]
there had been Simmons mountain dew
rising stars with the players first and
last name voting is open now for the MVP
Simmons Neely Keita
Felicio lost it
should stop dribbling boy
Simmons delivering to Abby play here in
the second
an all-star team he hammers 18 points
and nine rebounds and for most of the
season played well Belinelli takes the
handoff from Simmons marco belinelli has
just checked back in 36 is going to lay
up in the other end pretty play for
shards Ben Simmons right now with eyes
and back of his head he's got six
assists already Simmons great look and
that'll be the triple-double for Ben
[Applause]
that Simmons between the legs of
serenity
[Applause]
your dribble to get you somewhere how
about using a dribble to get the crowd
going nice five - JJ been in the crowd
love dribble handoffs so they're
difficult and remember both of these
teams make 11
worse than missed that time and here he
is
downhill bikes tuffington
[Applause]
Richardson to lead and now when he makes
that big step that's at 6:10 that's a
lot of space a chance to slip two spots
Oh between the legs
not just between his own legs sevens but
between Horford's legs as well look at
this
okay I'm gonna throw it to everybody
every turn my legs a shocker that's not
three of me and Simmons with the rebound
they can't get a good shot right now the
southeast cap the Philly just flips it
up
charge for three set up by sevens you
bet well it's the unwillingness and the
inability as well turnover though by
Boston off Simmons in transition
[Applause]
this is no phantom of the process this
is a man of the process my goodness
oh and here's Simmons coming up with a
turnover
look at that I didn't think I'd get that
excited in the preseason game good
instincts see right there no one's
playing them well let me free up this
opportunity for myself gets it back off
the boards finds a streaky Markel along
the baseline that's his smart basketball
Simmons just excellent play by Simmons
man Marcus Morris number three look at
that pass nice finish how about the
finish there's the cut my fault
once you guys playing together not a lot
of court time between these two last
year struggled in the first half it's
young for three and Simmons has it to
the sixer is nice spot of Covington who
throws it down the fifth assist of the
game for Simmons about how Roberts
defense sets up his office that time a
good challenge on tray you can feed off
the Bazemore miss sharukh Dario shards
really needed that Simmons the good spot
Zeller just the fifth three he's taken
this year he made one wow what a play
nice hookup between Simmons and Butler
Anderson all five of his points here in
the fourth
he seems to lead down to three
critically executed that time TJ
McConnell they're out there shooting
just 5 of 16 from the field
Simmons all beautiful whoops from
Simmons and the butler the Simmons
you've got to find a way to slow the
freight train down because if he gets by
and then that opens up your options and
a really good job by Butler to get
behind the defense Danny you can't let
him walk up into that mic he's too
smooth and you want to talk about a guy
who built this game that's one guy right
there is a nice little back cut by
Shannon Simmons drives my speed back to
maskala 4 that's as you see the vision
and pen Simmons wild past of a scholar
docket for Simmons back to JJ Redick
layup is happened bud he had a just
fling it at the basket Bowie trouble
Simmons knocked
ultimately the Sixers have it the near
steal by the Nets Simmons for a be
delayed at home a meeting well done by
Ben Simmons his second assist in the
first quarter sloughing off kind of
defense they don't get in your face they
don't pressure the ball that plug Butler
it's four three got it six is working
defensively here coming up with another
turnover it's a Redick three and reading
and the Sixers on a nice little sprint
here heated Brett Browns words press the
issue run the floor get open looks JJ's
not use that as an excuse and coach
Snyder told me today he said we just
forgot who we are to start the season
and Joey know sort of echoed the same
sentiment Simmons optimist by hurt or
his fourth rebound already so Simmons
steward at all a nice spot five down
that time for a leaking Jimmy Butler and
for Butler his first bucket
[Music]
JJ reddick carries the three we got
inside that four and sucker didn't get
it how they come the other way here
Simmons Jackson
mr. Rosen around the Aldridge screen and
it's tripped on the drive-by Brewer
Simmons leaves it crushes it
[Music]
fill it out here there's time and time
again this is the pressure puts on you
because not only does he do that
grant misses and it's popular he runs it
down Perry
to death
[Applause]
Channel four three oh nice Santa by
Simmons Alfonso McKenna his time Green
lurking to help behind the back Green
steps under him trying to land that's a
heck of a pass by Simmons a jump hook
right here and I see what Fremont green
is talking about to the rim again for
the punching Tobias Harris just fill in
Lane a look at to five in transition
thanks fine you can see Simmons stopped
by Isaac at his tracks would love
beautifully delivered a gorgeous play by
Simmons of Maine Rick brown tonsils
prior to the game about his team setting
better strains for Redick as Mike Scott
slipped open on the other end they're
holding Minnesota to 36%
along the baseline there it is partner
reddit complements as Simmons has got
four dimes here in the first quarter for
Harris has been very efficient in the
three-point line
[Applause]
helpin the defensive that hiccup I am be
here comes Simmons look away impede
bumped into head by Joelle the foul is
called on Joe Harris he picks up his
second very easy
watch it moments ago too easy at 801 by
the sixes zippy in the third quarter by
some great points as a Simmons was the
two-on-one hero Dennis as Harris of
course will be free agents this summer
he is so adept to join them - supplies
Leonard loses it Simmons two on one
throws at us throws it down
[Applause]
trying to set things up for Simmons now
back in on green shovels Scott squeezes
through for two that's what I'm talking
about right there's one win away from
their second Conference Finals in four
years nice pass
Simmons doctor puts it in Ben Simmons
with six assists Brett Brown likes to
say we took a college poor man and
turned him into an NBA point guard and
this is where he can make his Hegg
disability at 16
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content